we decided to speak to Patrick face to
face about on Zoom review of course as a
moderator and I think that was your
initiative and you should be giving
credit for that
um yeah because you I think you see
things that we don't see obviously being
in America having spoken to him haven't
had private conversations with him and
to be honest with you in that
conversation he came across as extremely
facilitating he came across extremely
humble
and a generous magnanimous
and so if anyone shows us that level of
energy I think it's only right for us to
respond in kind and he was very
concessionary in fact saying that you
know all of us
aspects that we've spoken about the
topic can include both Christianity and
Islam that there will be a co-host and
that you would be the co-host so it
would be instead of Patrick David being
uh the only person to host it it would
be you and Patrick but David which would
be which would kind of distribute uh